when i was four or five years old i  either wanted to be superman or i wanted  to be a former one world champion  when my visor comes down that's when my  mind definitely switches to a different  capacity and it's high octane  as an athlete i'm always looking how i  can be better  i'm going to be talking to you about  mental preparation how you can be laser  focused and have more energy  how you can feel healthier because the  better you feel the better you are at  doing your job  you might already be successful killing  it in whatever you're doing but i can  help you be better  my mastery is not the ability to put the  car on the limit  it's mastering my emotions and  understanding how to live into my  potential  i will show you what is possible  this is masterclass  [Music]  you